alright guys we're here in Crystal River
and the sun's just about to set and
we're gonna go on a very unique Charter
we're taking the kids out crabbing at
night with Nets so we're gonna be like
spotlighting crabs that night I'm really
excited this is gonna be fun are you
guys excited to go out at night being
out on the water at night is a
completely different experience than
being on the day it's just I love it you
guys got to be careful though the night
manatees are really aggressive they're
not like the day manatees you think are
you excited he's got the bat for bonking
the dog into really big crabs you got a
50 pound crab in the boat he can mess
people up you don't want to you don't
wanna bring one of those things live
look at that sunset isn't that pretty
Jacob I love what you're doing with your
hair as a wonderful thank you all right
guys we're hunting blue crabs so
apparently what we're gonna be doing is
dip netting so I'm excited I'm excited
I've I have fished for crabs with hand
lines and pots and this is my first time
I will have ever been dead at crab when
they're coming nice and smooth and just
kind of floating on the surface all you
do is just go like this get in front of
them and scoop them up when they're on
the bottom it's up to you some people
will take two Nets they work together
and they try to scoop up together like
that whoever's netic that's this salad
Tong technique that's the salad Tong
technique other people will go over the
top of them like this and pull and so
that they kind of slide into the net
that way whatever works for you some
people go down like this and then do a
quick twist and get them up in the net
so you can experiment with what works
best for you and just keep on trying
here's a short net for somebody that's a
little smaller if you see one out in the
distance like floating don't try to you
know just point him out to me and we'll
make a circle and we'll go right back
after Oh Tom Tom no hit and mom in the
head with her with it that's that'll get
you grounded buddy calmly you want to do
it first you guys you have any idea how
cool this is
I wouldn't give you my left arm to do
this with a little boy oh one hand oh
there's one oh thank you that one's too
far - I was a little bit here's one
[Music]
there's bit I got [ __ ] let go shake oh
there we go
oh there's one right there see him up
see him he's a little far away he's a
little far away though yeah there's uh
oh there's a big fish - keep your eye
out there there's one ther see him see
Yeah right there he's still there he's
still there he's right there go get him
from front yeah you did you do I saw you
drag them a little bit I'm picking are
you having a good time that's all right
it's not I got a feeling it's not gonna
be in the last one we see tonight we've
been doing this for like five minutes I
think we've already seen and missed like
seven crabs this is great there's one no
no well there's one right there see
emanate right there right there get him
get him
Oh Oh Nate you so close guys are you
having fun hey guys don't look
underneath you look ahead of you because
by the time you see one it's too it's
too late yeah
I with this if I see one I'll go and
I'll shine the flashlight on it okay
well there's one right there see him
perhaps one Nate zero because he got the
dead did we did there's one right there
see there's one right there right there
right there
wearing the lights I'm shining right on
them shadow right on dig deep right
there Tom big one big one gives me down
deep get down deep I get here I get here
oh he's running from you he's running
from you buttering him oh there's one
right there he's coming towards you babe
[Laughter]
come on what happened
did the crowd pull you in yeah you were
reaching for that one that was just a
little too far away that's all right
buddy we'll learn from this don't you
snuggle up with Mama chill she'll take
care of you okay there water your boots
well there's one right there Tom see him
right there
oh yeah big gar right there Oh big
spotted gar yeah that's crazy did I cut
this with salt water no the guard live
out here oh there's one right there see
it's right there for me yeah a little
bit closer just a few more feet and I
got them right in the Gator cooler there
we go big scoop down get it scoot down
scoot down no get him get him
that's all right he's right there he's
right there Nathan see him right there
that's him he hasn't moved yet now he's
Dorner dear buddy babe right there right
there
[Music]
now look at all these fish in here
there's a mullet right there oh there's
a nice one right there all right got him
right on a pike
never had so much fun catching crabs
well there you see that redfish right
there
snake and get that we get and put it
down low over the top of them here I'll
chase them into your net you got unaided
you got him oh I got him see it two and
one again they were doing the special
kind of oh oh look at that redfish yes
got a Remora he's got a remor on him see
him
[Music]
oh there's one Oh like a boss that one
made it look easy without the flailing
about that I'm normally used to it's
attacking hey Tommy you ready I can feel
it my crab bones are Jilin oh right
there that's that salami again you get
you got him you got him
come here Tommy come here come on come
here okay
[Music]
it turns out me careful you're hit and
jacob in the head is this so cool
there are so many fish out i can't tell
you how many red fish and mullet we've
seen and catfish and seen dolphins i
mean yeah everything comes out at night
it's awesome well oh yeah yeah it's big
enough i think we're gonna try oh he's
moving a little bit oh yeah there you go
oh you went right between the tines into
this Oh
I'm living the dream I have a spirit
what happened that in the other I'm just
I'm ready to hit anything yeah I can see
him I can see him just just pin him to
the freaking bottom no he went through
that he Wiggles right oh no I do have oh
it's all the way through there we go
great Nathan pull your net come sit down
we're gonna go fast guys we are having
so much fun I'm gonna put all the
information about this charter in the
video description if you want to check
this out check out Florida crabbing
charters calm here in Crystal River
Florida we are having a ball is a really
unique charter you have a fun time here
Nate once you come sit down sit down
here you can take a little nap if your
tire
I watch a hand me a jig oh he's got long
arms be careful that million that guy
whoa
his spread is gonna be 27 inches across
the pot oh yeah
look at his clothes are too we drove all
the way home to Virginia from Crystal
River Florida and we still have those
blue crabs live in the cooler in the
back of the car so we're gonna grab
those out and we are going to cook up
some blue crabs all righty
let's see yeah I got a shirt I got
Nathan's shirt that is monster yelling
so what they're doing green while I live
here in Virginia and I've done two
previous blue crab captain cook videos
so I am well aware that here in the
mid-atlantic there is a very specific
way to cook and shell and eat blue crabs
especially we go over in Maryland there
is one way to do it the Maryland way I
am gonna spit in the face of all of that
today and we're gonna do it the Florida
way just to try something different and
I'm gonna see if it really makes a
difference in Florida some people like
to clean their crabs before they cook
them yeah I know right so we're gonna do
that I'm gonna show you how to do it and
I'm gonna give it a go and we're gonna
see if it actually tastes better or
worse whatever compared to steaming them
the Maryland way all right the first
thing you want to do is you want to
freeze the crabs to death put them on
ice directly on ice put them in an ice
water bath and finish him off so they're
fresh but they're dead
okay otherwise they're gonna bite your
fingers while you do this okay
just pop the whole top of the shell off
get in here with the knife
rip that part off gonna take the face
off and then you gonna take all the
gills off then rinse out the guts now
the yellow stuff that I just rinsed out
that's the guts and the poo and
everything in Maryland they call that
the mustard okay and hardcore crowd of
enthusiasts like to eat that so if
you're not a hardcore crab enthusiast
you might be glad to try this method and
just chop that right down the middle
that's all the meat right there that's
the meat
rinse and repeat baby
[Music]
alright guys so we're gonna do a little
experiment here I've got steamed whole
crabs with old base sprinkled on top of
them the way
Marylanders do it and then I've got
these halved and clean crabs with
potatoes and carrots and an Old Bay
broth being boiled in the bottom so
we're gonna go and cook these all up
until they're all nice and red and we're
gonna eat them both and see if we can
taste a different all right guys here we
go
we got steamed Maryland style crab and
then we've got cleaned boiled Florida
style crab we're gonna give it a go and
of course we've got alligator curry in
here as well are you excited to eat that
yeah I want you guys to eat the Florida
style and one of the Maryland stuff so
you can compare and give your opinions
about whether there's a noticeable
difference in flavor here okay well guys
what do you think good my opinion on
this is they taste pretty darn similar
the Florida method of the meat was a
little bit bushier but I think that's
because we boiled it versus steaming it
I'd be curious to do the Florida way but
then just steam it and I think you would
come out almost exactly the same but I
sure like the Florida method because
it's quicker to clean them and it's a
whole lot less mess on the table if
you're eating outside with newspaper
yeah just just do it the Maryland way
but if you're inside I think I think
there's some value to cleaning up before
they get on the table guys I hope you
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more catch and cook videos definitely
check the playlist down below we've got
tons of videos like this and if you like
this video don't forget to click
Subscribe and put out new videos every
Saturday morning thanks for watching if
you like these
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys even channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button you'll
get notifications thanks for watch